we're on right yep okay hey guys we are
back for more game analysis we played
two games yesterday yeah more like one
and a half games double round at the
FISC open oh I put a training mode
because I didn't okay fair enough any of
the moves that's probably a good thing
it's so going into round 3 we were both
at two out of two we both won
so three out of three they're both be
candidate masters that's right that's
probably gonna be the title of the video
and the Masters be Canada masters yeah
your games seem pretty straightforward
mine was a little topsy-turvy but um
yeah yeah and we should note that wait
it's it's Tuesday it's Tuesday right
yeah yeah we were gonna record last
night but then I fell asleep at like 9
p.m. so it should be more awake though
around so anyway I was white the first
game and I play at London which I feel
like opponents should predict by now but
my opponent didn't seem too well
prepared like he started thinking after
Bishop f4 which is always a good sign
yeah and then he scared me cuz he was
playing okay slightly slowly in the
opening but then he played
what started as like a really trendy
line with C take T for he take T for and
a lot of people are playing this these
days is for Bach to play Knight h5 here
mm-hmm
now he didn't do that which made me
happy but for a moment I thought he
might go into this and I thought he
maybe he would have preparation on the
street with Bishop III yeah yeah so I
think the the first person to play this
was buzzy so against a nice Gary Wesley
was black and then it was some line like
Bishop g5 f6 Bishop b3 and it's really
nice prepped for a black if especially
if white isn't prepared I probably won't
go into this exact variation but for
example after castle
Bishop g2 and then if I'm not mistaken
very strong with f5 right idea of f4
oops
and for anyone who doesn't know what to
play against a London I can highly
recommend this line for black yeah
because I've seen a lot of players just
stumble into this as white and then I
think we showed yesterday on stream
after 95 f4 is very strong
yeah so anyway my opponent didn't go for
that which was nice
he played Bishop d6 mm-hm and then we
got a position which was very very
similar to my first round game which for
anyone watching if you haven't seen the
first video that we made from this
tournament we had pretty much in
identical position so the first round
game b6 was included right but I think
apart from that everything is the same
now hear my opponent Castle I think the
best move here his knight h5 and I would
have gone for the same line with bishop
take d6 Queen 286 and g3 yeah and I
would have already been comfortable
you're given that had almost almost same
position the first round so anyway he
castled which i think is just a mistake
because it allows 95 right away and it's
very hard for black to get any active
play is 95 I mean it's supported by buy
enough pieces and it facilitates some
later attack so game continues rook
eighty eight's Castle you plays Bishop
c8 just like the other just like the
first challenge yeah which I mean what
else does black do I mean this night
unfortunately for him doesn't have any
squares and really the only plan for him
is to play something like like moving
the night and then go for ass
the balancing sorry about that this
impromptu mic stand so yeah he moved his
bishop which i think is a decent move
because he wants to play like 97 and
then f6 right
so I improve rook e1 what did you call
this other day like the Pillsbury attack
Pillsbury yeah because you he always
played d4f for 95 and then just go
freaking yeah he was one of the first to
do this like ripped f3 Ricky I see stuff
yeah actually didn't hear of that term
oh I guess I'm not that well first in
chess history you got a study of the
classics okay so he played 97 after a
very long think and then I took a very
long think I was predicting 97 that I
probably should have calculated more
during his turn but then I was following
your advice of just not not knowing what
to expect I I was aware that I have like
a bunch of Canada moves here I can take
either night I can go for Queen h5 I can
go for f4 even maybe play Knight to f3
and I didn't really find anything that
satisfying I really wanted to play Queen
h5 which most forcing move but then he
plays g6 and there's so much pressure on
e5 and my Queens attacked I was thinking
about lines where I sac on g6 but I
don't think any of that works so I'm up
going for f4 wins
yeah I mean it allows f6 or f5 but I had
to allow something actually if he plays
f6 and I think I would play Queen h5
yeah there's a really nice position no
this looks like it's good for a white
right or at least he's forced to play
off all right so he played off five
immediately yeah make sense and then
then I played Bishop h4 just improve the
bishop and then he really surprised me I
was expecting that he'll go back to f6
and then play 94 yeah but he took on e5
I think is is quite dubious incredible
it just gives me this pawn on e5 and
it's just a bad French structure after
Knight of 6 how do you continue I wasn't
sure
that's why I took so long earlier
because I I saw this position coming
and I mean white should be better waste
of time right now white should be better
given the Knights on e5 this Bishop saw
the play my monitor pieces are slightly
better but 94 is gonna come and it might
be annoying so I was thinking the best
approach for white in this position is
to allow 94 and try and turn the night
into a decoration so try and make it
just play around the night and I was
thinking that I would probably just go
for something like King H 1 and then
ideas of like Knight DF 3 or up to you 1
and G 4 mm-hmm and I think that was a
decent approach to just ignore the
knight on e4 right so yeah that make
sense he has one good piece but you can
undermine it very easily yeah and this
is such a common idea and like structure
when black plays at 5 is to go for that
ntral g4 break and I think this is maybe
one reason one of the reasons why he
took on e5 was he probably just assumed
that the position is closed and it's
hard for me to break through but the the
looming idea of g4 is just so powerful
for white yeah and it facilitates very
strong attack later on right okay so the
game continues I avoid traded bishops
and then he shuffled around
I kept improving I just want to play
rough G 1 and G 4 so let's continue a
6th escape can free move plate rook f3 I
realized in this position that probably
one of the main targets is h7 pawn I
just wanted to play rogue h3 in Queen h5
so he played Bishop d7 ideas of Bishop
Yates and potentially Bishop g6 also
preventing Queen h5 and some lines so
now I play g4 nice and I mean I just
have more pieces to attack with on the
Kings side right I law that his pieces
on the Queen side are doing absolutely
nothing
yeah it's like ice oh really
about French now for black exactly just
so passive yeah where is this see pollen
to put pressure on before that's another
thing like there's no way to break apart
the center yeah and like he already
played that five so he can't play f6 so
the rest of the game it was some nice
just all momentum going in White's favor
but there is some nice kind of finish
through takes on g4 you just take on a
fate yes I would just take on that fate
and the fact that this a few lines have
opened up the diagonal for the bishop
and the file for the rook and the Queen
and I think this is just devastating for
black looks really strong knight Knight
f3 Knight g5 is coming so something very
similar happened in the game he played
g6 first I play rook g1 and then he took
so it's the same type of thing we
trained on our fates I take on g4 and
now I have threats of like Bishop take
g6 yeah he just really has his like rook
to defend so he played rook g8 I bring
the knight in and this is a nice example
like when you when you attack and Jess
you want to attack with all the pieces
and literally in this game all the
pieces play the role this is like a
dream position right like you could find
this and like heart attack or something
oh for sure and okay not to plug this
again but like the course that I was
working on like the last month I had so
many examples of this where it was just
king-size attacks where black isn't in
good shape to defend so that kind of
actually helped me find the the
breakthrough tactic a bit later yeah I
always think like the way to study any
opening is just to study these like key
middle games you might get right so you
know how to play them exactly rather
than just like memorizing very I think
it's a better approach yeah so okay I
bring the Knight to g5 I'm all aware
that if you you ever trades off the
darts for Bishop
okay so he played rook g7 and okay when
I played Knight g5 I was expecting or g7
and there's there's actually a nice
tactic here for whites just a very
forcing breakthrough
to win the game on the spots winning
combination exactly okay so if you want
to pause the video lets thing uh feel
free like to move and wane and then it
smoothest way possible do you do you see
it I didn't see it during the game I'm
looking at night takes age seven because
it just seems so tempting but I'm
wondering if there's something else your
first instinct is did yes so juicy
because they're okay there's a two lines
that calculates if work take a seven
then this is just winning because
there's all these meeting ideas and you
can't defend the rook
yeah Rick just has no squares right yeah
and then if King take this is what I
didn't see it first because I just
looked at Bishop take g6
or I just looked at Queen h5 oh um wait
what did I look at first I looked at
Bishop take g6 first but Queen h5 wait
what am I saying
no Bishop g6 is a winning move yeah and
this way you this wouldn't happen the
game also I didn't take on each seven
we'll get to that if okay if King g8 I
just play something like h7 and yeah I
win g7 and if you place King eh eights
then I check and then check and check
and then champions yeah nice so kind of
a feel good line
but when I played Knight take h7 there
is another move I had to calculate apart
from rook take h7 and King take h7 this
move Knight takes e5 and whenever you're
like looking to sacrifice you always
have to think about like counter play
counter sacrifices right so it looks
like a good attempt because he's trying
to muddy the waters and there's ideas of
like d4 and Bishop c6 right but I I
calculated this out and it's really
nothing to worry about because after I
take d4 there's this nice move Knight f6
Oh beautiful just threatening made into
with Queen h4 and he has no time to win
anything if he ever takes a knight I
take back and I attack the rook with the
pawn
so he played Bishop c6 Bishop before and
then okay then I was just up a piece I
was expecting him to resign here because
I just up a piece and there's no there's
no counter play for luck but you play it
on and it actually it finished off with
a nice a nice sack after rook aged six
we now for King g7 did you see the
finish white to move force mates oh sure
just finish six yes and he played it out
to mates which is nice beautiful so yeah
that's what happens when when you play
the London good things happen yeah that
looked effortless well it took some
effort like okay after after he took on
e5 then it was all the moves just came
naturally but before that if he had
played like nine f6 any for it would
have taken a lot more work to win the
game right there is one more thing I
want to show just another potential
Queen Zack yeah in this position if he
plays h5 I was really hoping this would
happen Queen take aged five and a knight
of seven mates mm-hmm so anyway there's
always potential to sack when you have
just so many pieces attacking yeah very
nice so all right let's save this that
was a nice one yeah I finish early and
then I don't know if you realize this
but I finished and then I wat like you
were thinking I walked like to your
board because I wanted to get the hotel
room key there's only one hotel room key
you're always holding on to it and you
didn't see me or I don't think you saw
me finish so yeah yeah I knew you're
when I gonna distract you
I didn't know if you're done or not but
then I took a long walk on the beach I
came back got some food oh oh you spent
a lot of time yes oh then I came back it
would have been fine I mean I had plenty
of time in my game yeah I was my
opponent who was in time trouble almost
the whole game but your game I mean I I
finished around the point where your
opponent already had like ten minutes
left
oh and then you were taking a lot of
time
because the position is really
complicated okay so yeah it was a tough
game
I started around this moment here so I
was I was playing black got another
Kings Indian fee and Cairo variation
here I felt really comfortable with the
structure my Knights coming to d6 and I
mean I feel like black is kind of in
charge on the Queen side with these
pawns and like the C file white knight
on d1 bishop on g2 I mean these are
really bad pieces but I you know I got
over overconfident here I felt like the
position is just gonna win itself
basically okay I pushed a four I grabbed
Brooks e8v three hitting my queen so I'm
just trying to get in as many moves as
possible before that happens
it's strange in the King's Indian for a
black to be attacking on the Queen side
especially when you see the structure in
the center of a t4 and d5 usually white
cilantro yeah I think it happens more
frequently in the fianchetto variation
because their bishops on g2 and not on
like E - or would normally um cover all
these squares and because like the King
side is safer so it's harder for blocks
to get anything going here but it you
know it kind of depends on the structure
but here I actually kind of expected we
would get this which should be three
Queen a5 Bishop d2 and I already had
this move in mind rook c2 and it seems
like very uncomfortable for white if he
takes on a five I'll take on e - and I
have to be very careful that my rook is
not getting trapped here but I am
hitting the e4 pawn and there's one line
I calculated that goes like in this
Knight c3 rug G - your favorite movie
yeah in Knight see for the double attack
on the bishop and 93 checks and the big
bigger problems that he's forced to give
up the bishop because it just has no
square so I can I was very much hoping
to get this position on the board at the
bishop
yeah exactly so bishop pair his King has
to go passive to defend h3 pawn at 5:00
Sunday yeah dr. sweets yeah I would
start with this one most likely to
threaten a3 and I felt like this is just
very close to winning four black bishops
coming out and so on of course he's not
obliged to go further but just an
example of like how this can turn bad
very quickly this is reminiscent of your
is it your second round game or you just
control the only open file and then you
penetrate somehow oh yeah what they file
for why it's good strategy to control
the pilots absolutely okay he played the
only move rook f2 kind of an
uncomfortable move but what else are you
gonna do now my queen is hanging and I I
kind of regret not just going back like
Queen b6 then he might play like 93 I
thought and just retreat and I feel like
objectively I think the engine says
white is fine here but I would still
take black I think I I definitely have a
lot of play here especially given at
this point it's like I think he's
already down to 20 15 minutes or so and
I have like maybe 50 minutes so it's a
great position for that time situation
yes it's gonna be a long game from here
exactly
blockade so many pieces and and so on
but I pushed b4 is that I felt like this
was stronger and this is still fine the
idea is to just get the Bishop to b5 she
looks really annoying but he plays 93
I'm forced to to go back I was thinking
about taking on d2 and Bishop h6 but
White has a nice reputation here I mean
you can take the e5 pawn but there's
something even even simpler well you're
threatening Knight c4 that's right we'll
just move the Queen somewhere Queen e2
Queen to Bishop b5 so this is the
Knights this is what I would hope for
yeah but he has an immediate way out as
a knight c4 yeah hey
pieces in my position mm-hmm and white
is just winning Bishop h6 is hanging and
I Queen egg is hanging nothing's
defended so I would just be lost here so
I can't do that
I just went back and I was expecting him
to play a3 and so I was actually just
you know and anticipating a nice
positional pawn sacrifice here because
my ideas not to I mean I can't defend
the pawn anymore I'm just gonna play
Bishop b5 probably takes with the pawn
not to give up his Bishop something like
Queen b6 and I felt like this position
just uncomfortable for a while yeah yeah
I have the C 4 square Bishop h6 it looks
it's amazing how your bishops can like
activate and what seems to be a very
close position but you you find some
nice open lines yeah I have the the
right diagonals yeah but then he he
surprised me with this move Queen e1
which I completely overlooked because
now he's hitting the pawn and he's
getting out of the pin and so here I I
start to go wrong and I think this was
the result of just like my
overconfidence I felt like the position
should be so good I can do basically
anything I ended up choosing a three my
idea was that if he takes then Queen
takes he can take the pawn on b4 I'll
play Knight c5 and it's like almost like
a Banco gambit just huge Queen side play
his pieces are still passive Knights are
good I felt like black is doing great
here he has to defend the e4 pawn maybe
Knight see - I'll move my queen
somewhere where it's bothersome and just
hard to move for white still you know
his eight pawns never going anywhere the
engine points out b3 was really strong
which I completely missed and now he
just wants to take the b4 pawn
essentially for free you have to play
like rook e8 but then he has a nice seat
exactly rook b8 you'll get Knight c2 and
and so or even just rook c1 and so he's
just can you played much better six
instead then maybe nine c4 is a problem
again
that looks complicated yeah I should
tell you - there should be - yeah
actually I'm not sure about this one um
cuz it's like his Queen and his bishop
are kind of tied down to the fang the
993 yeah they're both they're both
hanging no you want to do this like one
I guess you can just take the e5 fun oh
I forgot about that
yeah yeah well so many issues for black
then yeah this is this is bad and yeah
Bishop's hanging on d7 so well I don't
know what I would have done here
to be honest I'm lucky he didn't find
this move during the game I also didn't
see it so it's kind of like a mutual
blindness but it's a very very nice move
maybe just like Queen b6 and Troy and
Leon
yeah I would have to do that hopefully I
would bond realize the danger at this
point and start to make better moves he
ends up taking on b4 with the bishop
which I was very happy to see just
giving up the dark square bishop I
understand why he does this because he
can force a trade of Queens but I felt
like even in the Sun game black should
still have the initiative with the dark
square Bishop mm-hmm okay 91 and I end
up blundering here with Knight takes e4
it's yeah it's tough to explain you know
I had enough time but this is the
problem again of being overconfidence
like your opponent has a low time your
position is good everything seems to
work hmm so 94 is just a slip I think
after and it looks like a good move it
first you want to like win yeah it looks
like it's working it's a good exercise
to try and figure out why Knight takes
e4 it is not working but a normal move
like maybe f5 and I think black is just
better either I get the past a pawn or
one way or another and but the idea here
is okay whenever he takes this pawn on a
three you know like his to a pawns are
just very very very hard to push and
it's not like he's up to pawns here at
least it doesn't doesn't feel like that
I can take on e4 and just have I think
just have the initiative but yeah okay
Knight takes e4 he takes rook c4 this is
my idea
and then after 93 I realized soups
Knight c5 is coming at the end and I'm
just I saw this and I forgot about it
and yeah it's tough so then I checked
with the engine like the engine it's
just like it is incredible it points out
this move Bishop g7 what the idea being
that okay he moves the bishop I get a
foreign and I just got like a lot of
compensation wow it's hard to evaluate
during the game whether you're gonna
have enough for a piece because my pawn
is stuck but okay I have ideas like
Bishop a4 maybe rook c1 Bishop a4
efficiency to potential yeah and as long
as his bishop on g2 is out of play okay
I have compensation but that's hard to
see yeah I think you know usually you'd
rather be down in exchange than down a
piece right so I end up just taking on
e4 Knight c5 and Bishop f5 I figured
this was the best the engine points out
another amazing move here rook e1 again
just giving up the piece but going for
this like positional domination but
there's an amazing point here I don't
think humans could find this well maybe
maybe some a few select humans but like
white just keeps the piece right Knight
g4 anyways just all the piece here yeah
and what it seems like White House
initiative like check and then attack
the bishop okay but black has this
resource f5 takes rig d5 what 91 has
lost nine rh6 istra nice traps yeah
but I'm actually glad I didn't find this
because had we gone for this position I
mean look White's moves are all forced
right wait it's black then it's just
kind of equal right simplify he can just
bail out right and so we were we would
get this and I think black will this is
to draw get a draw but I'm still trying
to win the game right so it's like even
though objectively this is a better
choice it kills my winning chances cuz
his moves are all forced and obvious and
he's a strong player especially in time
trouble he was finding I think a lot of
good moves
so yeah object Lee this moves better but
a pro impractical point of view I think
just keeping the two bishops on the
board seems better because I actually
felt like this position even though he's
up in exchange in a pawn there's
actually not not so clear just do so
strong like open positions yeah and like
even the computer can underestimate the
power of two bishops oh for sure so well
I think just they give a big practical
advantage because they control so many
squares and I can anchor it with f5 in
the future mm-hmm I had a similar game
against um international master Michael
Brooks you probably know him I've heard
of him yeah where I was like same
material just up in exchange you know no
compensation
he had rook and two bishops and just
like outplayed me effortlessly and just
won based on you know two bishops being
a lot stronger objectively he did miss
one chance for an advantage here so
Knight c3 I played Bishop d3 and here he
should have played rook e1 just stopping
me from solidifying with e4 mm-hmm
and then I think white is slightly
better here but it's still very tricky I
might have to play like Bishop g7 in the
game he played rogue d1 just logical but
now I play e4 and I just anchor this
piece that's nice and a5 coming I pick
pawn chain exactly now even though i
blundered I'm still I'm still ambitious
right I'm still trying to win I was a
little bit concerned that he's just
gonna like counter SAC at some point
mm-hmm because he's likely fine with a
draw even though he's kind of up but
white doesn't really bail out in this
position because I'll just put the pawn
on d2 and he can either blockaded with
the knight or he can attack it but he
can't do both so I'll have time you know
he'll need to bring his King in I can
activate my rook I still think Black has
some chances here although this would be
because White's pawns are so
yeah exactly his deep on I can cover my
king actually I might just be concretely
winning here with it just Rick CA Rick
cc1 coming and he has a hard time hard
time stopping this but no he he just
takes on a three I think makes sense
just taking the pawn
I played rook c8 now it's tough as night
has no no good squares c2 and c1 are
both covered so he can't defend it I was
thinking he might play Knight a4 and
trying to play like Knight b6 I think I
was planning on playing Bishop III here
hitting the rook I don't know where he
puts his ship C to work um yeah Bishop
c2 I was trying to work make it work but
I I wasn't short to do about 96 if I
could and you take and play e3 oh right
right take take your pawn looks strong
this nights out of play but he has a
deep on e3 this is complicated
yeah I couldn't figure this out during
the game uh-huh but it looked as he
could he's wrong
oh he can't play d6 oh maybe he could
play d6
no you look like Bishop g5 take yeah
Bishop g5 is enough oh right right
and then if 97 King f8 you can't advance
the decline yeah yeah it is nice for him
that his knight does cover the square so
my King can't stop the punt yeah this is
working for white but maybe we may be
looking move the rook F 1 e2 rook e1 and
then if you play Bishop d2 then d6 and
it's such a weird position right come on
Bishop d2 oh you have Bishop a5 a6 yeah
take and okay bishops are good and if
here oh that should just be winning
probably not enough right it's still
Bishop a5
and just hear and whites not in time
yeah so I guess this is working for
black but yeah during the game I wasn't
exactly sure what to make of this it was
one of those things like okay we'll see
where he puts the night because
eventually he just took on e4 kind of a
kind of a lout which was probably a
mistake the engine gives 92 is the best
move but like this is hard to allow rook
to see to the point though is that rook
c2 I think he can play d6 here well it's
all about getting counter play yeah
exactly and and like Bishop g5
eventually he'll he'll play like rook b1
at some point and and come down to BAC
that would have been the critical line
at this point but I understand why he
bails out and now I mean he has a lot of
past pawn still and so rook versus two
bishops if the rook has any chances it's
in this kind of position or White has
passed pawns but I felt well this is the
best position I've seen in a while
of course so I felt better here like the
trend is going my way and I didn't I
didn't play accurately though to win
this unfortunately these moves are
alright I think white has to just kind
of start pushing king f7 a6 and here I
really just wish I played any move like
Bishop e3 for example because King e6
this is a good actually opportunity if
you guys want to pause the video and try
to figure out what white should do here
because white is definitely worse I mean
why does fighting to to create enough
counter play to draw if I win all of
white spawns then the two bishops are
just too strong but I think there's one
key element in the position that white
has to think about rather than and and
not allow block basically to to
consolidate it's kind of vague but any
ideas what what should do here well I'm
aware of that like if if you ever trade
off your rook even if you and the D fun
like rotate you 6:42 1686
it is hard for the
to bishops to win a funds right because
they can only blockade exactly so I'm
wondering if just d7 yeah absolutely I
think this is the only move to remember
the Carlson carjacking game in the play
the world championship playoff they had
some end game like this I think there
were three pawns on the kingside yeah
three versus had like one past a pawn
with two bishops against her rook mm-hmm
and I forget what happened I think it
ended in a draw but Carlson had some win
with the two bishops yeah but it's very
difficult for the two bishops to win
this yeah that was an interesting mu I
mean eventually he does manage to win
the pawn they just had three versus
three theoretically that positions
supposed to be a draw uh-huh which is
really interesting I I didn't know this
but like I had a game once when I had
like the same end game three versus
three two bishops versus rook I during
the era thought Oh easy win it shouldn't
what is this right but then I was
talking to Armin resume Ian he was
working with a little bit at the time
and he's like no this is well known it's
a draw because the two bishops can't
attack anything twice I guess that's
true right Bishop a knight easy you
attack something twice and you take it
game over two bishops not the same but
Carlsen managed to apparently he missed
some forced wins in that game but yeah
this is absolutely the right move based
on the idea that if white can trade off
the rook then blacks winning chances are
greatly diminished especially because as
a pawn is annoying and he can support it
with like Rosie be second you have to
put your king yeah probably King b8 King
c7 and yeah it's it's tough because like
I think rook b3 might be a critical move
here just to stop Bishop e3 yeah so it's
not not easy for white to hold anything
a7 and rope e8 so you must be careful
here yeah that's true that's true so
well yeah I mean this is the dream
version for white in this kind of
endgame
I think objectively it's still equal but
yeah I mean both sides probably ought to
be I guess at a seven you have Bishop b7
so right right still has this then the
second a Ponk comes that's scary
then you have to reposition your doors
for a bishop yes they'll double edge
maybe I tried bishop f8 or something to
come to c5 but yeah I feel like that was
his that was his best chance and I think
he didn't realize but after I think d7
it's not the type of move you calculated
it's just the type of move you should
understand
yeah it's based on understanding he
probably thought the pawn has lost
anyway so why waste the temple but I
think he he didn't realize it after Rick
B - I just want to play King d7 right
nice and here I felt like I should be
winning because b7 is covered he has no
way of improving his position the a 8
squares cover twice so I'm just like
very secure Bishop on e4 is great but
actually I give him a chance to get back
into it ok rugby six I play rook c8
trying to come to c2 he backs up Bishop
g7 and here I'm just like seizing total
control he pushes a7 and okay I tried
rook c3 here based on calculating this
nice line so I thought he would play
rookie - trying to take the bishop and
Queen then I would play roof takes g3 if
he Queens its immediate checkmate just
rip anywhere mm-hmm that's nice and then
if he takes the bishop
I just calmly recapture and I have the
discovered attack does he have worked d5
here yes I think probably just Bishop f4
oh that's simple okay
I'm not sure if I have another move but
yeah this is a5 you still play rock a3
check yeah exactly I'm always in time to
get behind the pond but he he found the
only move which I was hoping you
wouldn't play ouch
and actually there is I was so close to
making this move but it just doesn't
work
Queen Bishop to e3 or Brooksie to Trixie
- because if King g1 I can push them to
h1 right and then I'll have Bishop e4
check at the end but he can take on you
400 d4 is hanging also right
oh that's share of issues oh I see and
then wait a mine time those are pushed
the e pawn I think just rookie for King
g2 but I'll I'll Queen o king of King g1
then right now tricky for first right
otherwise I give check yeah II to King
g1 and whites fine yeah yeah should be a
draw okay well yeah fortunately for me
he has an even easier defense he can
play queen g2 mmm and just we get the
same in-game I see okay I took his a
pawn but right at this point no I don't
want to go for this if I don't I don't
have to now it was very funny here so
like my intuition told me to just give
the check because if he plays rugby rook
1 d2 then his coordination I think is
all messed up and I'll just go back
mm-hmm and then his rook is hanging and
then if he goes here I'll come in with
rookie c1 guys
so this looked very good for me but of
course I figured okay well he'll
probably just repeat the position or
just go back and then I thought well
let's do this and then go back and then
it's his turn again he has to make a
move the problem earlier with let's say
just plain working and taking the pawn
is I didn't want to deal with rook c1 so
I figure at this point he's probably
gonna realize that his situation is
desperate he needs to trade the rooks at
all costs and so again I don't want to
have to win this right
but then at the during the at the board
with rugby 3 I was like well why give
the check I just went back immediately
assuming he would repeat mm-hmm and then
I would just find it's the Greg shahadat
admit your mistake and revert yeah and
then I would play some other
maybe h5 because it's hard for him to
improve it all with both of his rooks
here but he finds the right idea he puts
plays rook a3 he activates his rock
while he still has the chance I thought
this move was impossible because of Rick
see to check but turns out I'm not
actually mating sin or not Bishop d4 can
you play like rook g2 and Bishop a 8 and
then just try and I don't know your
thread is yeah I would definitely be
worried about losing coordination right
because I don't really have huge threats
maybe he just wants to play rook e1 rook
b8 exactly yeah he he just starts
harassing me and he's always ready to
promote so I I ended up deciding to play
just Bishop 8 immediately nice and now I
think he missed the only move King g1
just improving the King mm-hmm
in the game he ends up blundering with
rugby 1 which is um well logical
obviously wants to play rugby 8 now I
could take the d6 pawn and and I think
I'm just slowly winning there mm-hmm
but it's a good exercise again it's
blocked to play try to find the
strongest move and I didn't realize this
during the game but it turns out to be
like made intend from this block yeah
that's the start of the check
no no but I did realize I did realize
the move is just winning like I'm I am
meeting by force I didn't know how many
moves I figure he can like give up a
rook or something to avoid the mate so
it's not receipted it's not rook c2 this
thing will get out yeah yeah this is um
I think that's one of those like once
you see it then you then you start
appreciating um how strong it is
I don't see it I have no appreciation
I was looking at Bishop b2 or take me to
rook c1 but then there's Richie - mm-hmm
okay so maybe just f4 just break break
through stuff f4 okay well I think he
takes in King g1 and so there's there
won't be a king is too open
what other ideas exist I mean there's
there's Bishop b4 - it just attack the
rook and maybe improve the bishop and
prepare Roxy to
it's made in 10 yeah with the cornice
Wow yeah the game lasted fewer moose
because he didn't just give up all his
rooks but okay yeah where the meet
threats yeah I would say in practical
terms it's made in like five or six
really and the first move is not a check
quiet move yeah
where are the quiet moves I mean h5h for
but if you late if we play h5 he plays
h4 we could play g5
[Music]
think I'm stumped yeah it's going for
the viewers okay got a tighten the noose
Oh or just threatening Rexy - yeah we're
preventing King do you on yes as long as
this little stuck it's really nice he
has no way of defending so obviously you
play like rugby to here but apparently
this is still like Maidan mm-hmm you
know ten or whatever I just take and
then probably come back I forgot he just
can't stop Rick see - yeah so just
control G 1 and that's so he has to
create an escape square like g4 if he
plays h4 I have a nice mate with Rick
see - and she - Bishop f3 Bishop g4 yeah
we all know rigmarole definitely
important theme and so it's actually
funny the game actually I didn't give
any checks to mate like g4 I just play
yeah I mean I was calc cuz I still had
time here so I was calculating okay rook
c2 Bishop e5 but the King somehow always
sneaks out right so I was like okay
what's the problem f4
he plays h4 and now I could give the
check first but I just played h5 because
I need to control the g4 square in order
to make this Bishop g2 Bishop f3 Bishop
g4 very nice he plays King h3 I bring in
the rook takes takes it looked great for
us mate without giving like tightening
and tightening right yeah well you know
I'm positional player I don't like to
attack okay could resign here okay just
play rugby it you know whatever he
realized to you he was just losing and
now actually can go back anywhere on the
diagonal but Fisher f3 is cleanest and
that was released efforts yeah so you
know not not a clean game by any stretch
definitely uh runners with the 54th at
home but that was yeah that was a cute
finish there
alright let me save this yeah
and so in round four we ended up Yeti
hard
I don't think we'll go over that game
it's kind of an unfortunate because yeah
obviously we're room a ting here and but
it was a small open tournament so at
some point we likely would have played
anyways if you guys do want to check out
that game it is on chest 24 I was
playing white we went into some endgame
traded off all the pieces and agreed on
a peaceful result if I move 20 yeah but
now today we have round five yeah so
probably what I'll do is I'll schedule
this video to be uploaded at the
beginning of round five or maybe even
earlier mm-hmm so then if you're
watching this video right after or right
when it's posted you're watching this
video right now but you are by
definition you can click the link in the
video description and you can watch our
games I'm on board seven you're on board
three okay some more so both our games
will be broadcast live yeah you can
watch our live games from from round
five the tournament situation is there
are two players with four points a bunch
of players including us with three and a
half and two GM's other AIIMS we're both
playing somewhat down but these players
have three and a half so they're clearly
pretty serious yeah so we got a prep eat
sleep go to the beach yeah so we'll be
back for hopefully another video with
good news or at least good games yeah
and and yeah I guess all right take care